the initial earthquake struck overnight
on the East Anatolian fault line that
runs through southern turkey and it's
7.8 on the magnitude scale is by far the
largest in the region in living memory
this map shows the worst of the shaking
in red tracing the fault line as it runs
close to the city of gaziantep but the
power of the Quake meant it affected
hundreds of other cities and towns in
the region see here where orange and
yellow lines show significant shaking in
Syria and Tremors felt as far as Cyprus
then there are aftershocks shown here in
Orange are the typical Quakes
diminishing in magnitude and frequency
along the fault line over the morning
but what makes this event so unusual is
that nine hours after the initial Quake
a huge 7.5 magnitude Aftershock almost
as strong as the first happened here 100
kilometers to the North in Cameron
Morris province as well as being violent
both the initial quake and that
Aftershock were relatively shallow in
the Earth's crust 18 and 10 kilometers
deep respectively the closer to the
surface the more damage a quake will
cause
turkey and Northern Syria are vulnerable
to earthquakes they sit at the junction
of four tectonic plates with fault lines
along their margins these latest Quakes
occurred on what's called a strike slip
fault the Anatolian plate is being
pushed westwards at a rate of about two
centimeters a year by the Northwood
movement of the Arabian plate and it was
the sudden release of this stress that's
built of many decades that caused this
disaster
and in geological terms it's one of
turkey's worst the town of Izmit was
shaken by a 7.6 magnitude earthquake in
1999 killing more than 17 000 but not
since 1939 has there been an earthquake
as violent where more than 30 000 people
died in a 7.8 magnitude Quake around
ersen can
but crude measures of geological Force
don't tell us much about the human scale
of this tragedy it will be days before
that becomes clearer